hey everyone I'm Liam Miller one of
Samuels students and recently we
completed on our first a buy refurbish
refinance deal so this is part two of
the refurb documentary if you haven't
checked out part 1 then check the
description down below I'm sure it'll be
there so in today's video you'll see a
massive difference from the house
several weeks ago to what it is today
it just looks completely different so
you'll be able to see where we split the
bathrooms where we split the bedroom
we've put windows in to the second
bedroom and where we've kind of carved
out for the ensuite and the bathrooms
downstairs too hey everyone so it's been
seven weeks since we started our refurb
projects and it's actually coming along
really nicely so we are going to get a
new front door like thankfully because
this one is like really old so it's
gonna get a new one and just restart
that so we've stripped out most of the
areas in the house and then I'll show
you the first room in a minute the gas
meter is here on the floor so this is
going to be someone's bedroom so we're
going to have that moved outside and put
in a box so that we can access it from
the outside and then we're going to have
smart meters installed as well very soon
so we've got two double sockets which
would be either side of the bed we are
actually happen to have a full rewire in
everywhere apart from the kitchen
because that was an extension so all the
electrics are okay in there apart from
the rest of the house
so yeah that's being done today so we're
gonna get the windows replaced we're not
gonna replace the frames but just the
actual glass because our builders really
creative so he knows how to do that at
the minute they're just single glazed so
I'm gonna get it changed to double
glazing okay so this is the second
downstairs bedroom so we've had the stud
wall put up here which is just like
blocked it all off and then that's
created a corridor and then this is the
room here it's super just a super messy
the bed will go on this back wall here
and then we'll have a built-in wardrobe
over here and there
we're gonna create some sort of storage
sort of unit in the fireplace and then
the TV can go on the wall there here
we're going to put a ensuite bathroom so
this is the only one with an ensuite so
we've just kind of like gone into the
kitchen a little bit to create the space
for the ensuite bathroom and then we're
cutting out a window here as well
because there was like no light in here
at all there was just no windows so we
had to cut one in this will be the best
room in the house like the most
expensive one because it's got the
ensuite and it's like right next to the
kitchen so this is the best one okay so
what could for the new corridor now that
leads through to the kitchen but before
the kitchen we have a new bathroom under
here so this bathroom will be for the
first bedroom so we've just kind of
taken the space under the stairs and
then a little bit into the kitchen as
well so what we've done is there was a
door that led out to the garden we've
just like boarded that off and then now
we've created a new bathroom then in the
kitchen on this side under the worktop
so we're going to have the washer and
the dryer and the boiler from the
bathroom it's going to be moved down to
here so there's gonna be a lot going on
so that's happening tonight so yeah a
lot of work tonight so this will be the
prep area for the tenant so the sink is
gonna stay where it is and then to the
side of that they can prep all their
food and under the worktops as well
there'll be two fridge freezers then on
the right hand side here that's where we
will have two ovens and that's where
we're going to have a long cob so they
can all cook their food so that's like
the cooking area then we've got the prep
area and the washing area and in the
middle we're gonna have a breakfast bar
and under there we'll have three
fridge freezers so everyone's gonna have
their own fridge freezer so hopefully
they'll be no arguments over stolen food
okay then we're also gonna put a TV on
this wall because this will be the
communal area before the tenants so
we've already had a virgin media fiber
Wi-Fi install so when the tenants do
in Italy all good to go okay so these
are the three bathrooms
so we've split the original bathroom
into three the first two bathrooms so
this one here and this one these are
going to be shower rooms so basically
the shower tray will be the entire
bathroom floor and then they'll be a
wall-hung toilet and a basin so it's all
very compact in there but it means they
can all have separate bathrooms the
boiler used to be here and that's going
to move downstairs like literally
directly downstairs so you can see here
how we've managed to split the bathrooms
and still get them to be a decent size
so yeah that'll have their own private
bathroom and they won't have to share
then the last bathroom is slightly
bigger so the shower will have its own
door and things like that it would still
be a walking toilet and a basin and
obviously we're gonna get rid of this
toilet here the guys are just using that
for now so now we've also split the
fourth bedroom into a fifth bedroom and
I was personally really surprised at how
big the fifth bedroom still was I found
it hard to imagine in my head how big
the bedroom was going to be but it's
still of a good size so really happy
about that okay so this is the room we
created as the fifth bedroom so it is
slightly smaller than the other ones but
it does comply with the standards so
we've had the HMO officer out twice and
he said it's all fine and we can use the
kitchen as the communal area so that's
really cool and then here we're going to
create a nice built-in wardrobe for them
so they'll have lots of space and then
above the Wardrobe there'll be some
space for them to put things like their
suitcases or any bags that they have to
the TV will go here on the wall and then
we're going to create the Wardrobe here
to save some space so the bed's gonna go
over here we've already put the sockets
out where they're going to go and we're
gonna get optimum beds for all of them
so they've got more space and they can
put their stuff under their bed and yeah
so this is the fourth bedroom we put the
stood wall up to divide the two rooms
then we're gonna have the TV on the wall
over here so then where you put the
socket in for that then we've got a
socket over there for their desk is
gonna go we've got two sockets here for
either side of the bed and then the
built-in wardrobe will go over here so
yeah it's all coming along very nicely
so this bedroom is slightly bigger than
the other bedroom okay so we have
changed the entrance slightly for this
room the door was kind of along here
before and then we've moved it here and
we've created a sort of corridor that
goes through for this wall here we've
had to take down the original wall and
put up a stud wall because the wall was
so damaged it just made more sense to
just start again with the stud walls
that's what we've done so the bed will
go here we've really got the sockets put
in we've got a socket over here as well
for the desk over here that's all we'll
have built-in wardrobes so yeah it
should be working on that soon
so originally we felt we're gonna have
to replace the whole roof which was
going to cost us around five grand and
then luckily once the Builder had got up
there he said we didn't need to replace
the whole thing just a few tiles so that
saved us a good few grand so this is how
they'll access the garden they'll have
to come out for you the front door now
so this is where we've had to brick in
the wall up for the inside to create the
new bathroom so this is the garden that
lived us tired stripping everything out
it looks like way better than it did
before
say what's this little stripped out and
we've put grass down it'll be a really
nice big garden so we are gonna put a
new fence up to divide from the
neighbors because the original fence was
broken it's still a decent-sized garden
I feel like when we first completed on
the house I was really worried and once
we've got the keys and I'd walked into
the house I remember thinking there is
so much work that needs doing and I
think I got really scared that for the
refurb it was going to take more money
than we had initially thought the
biggest expense we thought we were gonna
have was the roof and but it actually
turned out fine and it came in a few
grand less
than we thought so that was really good
and really nice so yeah we're not too
over budget which is really good it's
been really fun working with mom as well
on this project we've both really
enjoyed doing this refurb and we're so
excited to do more it's also been really
nice with this project because of my dad
has also got involved in it as well and
he's been going around and meeting the
builders to make sure they're on
schedule so it's really nice that dad
has finally got involved in the property
journey with us so this is Tony our
builder so you just wanted to know from
your perspective how's it all going yeah
we're getting there
stopped ripping everything out now
started putting stuff back scaffolds
down roofs being overhauled main cost of
that was the scaffold that's to save
some money their chimneys been repointed
all the lead flashings been repaired and
renewed now we're on the inside stuff oh
good so how long did you think it'll
take now now we're like seven weeks in
why'd you ask that at five more weeks
hopefully we think we've uncovered all
of the problems rectified now we're just
putting back all right thank you for
your time Tony and I'll leave you to it
now Jason so I hope you enjoyed part two
of our refurb video for part three
you'll get to see the final project and
we'll be talking about the figures so
what the tenants are going to pay and
the refinance figures and how we pull
most of our money out which is really
exciting and if you enjoyed this video
be sure to give it a thumbs up and
comment down below and don't forget to
subscribe to Samuel amazing channel and
I'll see you next time bye
[Music]